madnodje plus
bas que ça m'embête un peu les mois sq
parce qu'en fait je peux pas très bien
réussi un pari ça m'embête un peu ça
pour ça plutôt pratique parce que des
gens d'en haut lieu l'épreuve
effectivement et puis du coup on peut
voir nos camarades on peut mettre du
rouge à lèvres ces pratiques et du sable
je trouve ça bien sûr puis ça fait du
bien de voir des visages et pas des
masses etc je trouve que c'est mieux
parce que déjà on voit mieux les gens à
qui on s'adresse
après je trouve que ça permet de pas
avoir de mal de tête à la fin de la
journée parce qu'avec le mas est
vraiment c'est ses galères mais oui bah
on sent un peu libéré parce que ça fait
quand même deux ans qu'on est avec le
masque et ouais c'est vrai que ça fait
du bien je trouve que c'est une bonne
chose dans le sens où bas on respire
mieux simplement maintenant j'ai pu
remarquer que pour beaucoup d'étudiants
ça a été sacrée et ça a été une source
de stress parce qu'on n'a jamais vu les
visages des uns et des autres et ça
réveille réveiller certains complexes je
pense que c'est un soulagement un petit
peu pour tout le monde aujourd'hui on a
vu des gens heureux on a vu les gens
revivre un peu avec l'opus le soleil
tout parfait et je pense que moralement
les j'en avais besoin c'est un
soulagement pour les commerçants pour
nous en tant que citoyens et puis en
espérant qu' effectivement il n'y ait
pas une remise en question sur justement
le fait qu'on ne porte plus le masque à
partir d'aujourd'hui c'est génial on se
sent libre